on c-span's q a
[Music]
in washington dc ruthless fanatic
violence erupted in the halls of
congress three men and a woman believed
to be members of the puerto rican
nationalist gang that in november 1950
attempted the assassination of president
truman
opened fire from the visitors gallery of
the house of representatives
five congressmen were hit ben f jensen
of iowa clifford davis of tennessee
kenneth roberts of alabama george h
fallon of maryland and albert bentley of
michigan who was seriously injured
observers noted the attack came as the
inter-american conference opened in
venezuela and it suggested the motive
may have been to arouse anti-united
states feeling in latin america through
an act of apparently blind violence
carefully calculated to inflame
america's relations with her neighbors
[Music]
estimates of the numbers of shots fired
range from 15 to 30 and each bullet hole
found as a grim reminder to those who
were present of the terrible surprise
attack
the gang seized by shocked bystanders as
they emptied their guns was held at
police headquarters as a widespread
search was launched for others who
shared in the plot
[Music]
to irving forrest raphael miranda mrs
lolita lebron
andre cordero the gun wielders and to
their accomplices goes the evil
distinction of having perpetrated a
criminal outrage almost unique in
america's history
wanton violence that shocked and stirred
the nation and did only harm to the
cause of the puerto rican people
bullet holes can be seen in the house
chamber from shots fired in 1954 by
puerto rican nationalists
march the 1st 1954 and that's when the
four puerto ricans
entered the capitol
and the house gallery where i was
working
and began to shoot into the chamber
five members of congress were wounded no
one died
i was a staffer at that time in the
gallery and our position was to sit at
the apex of the other gallery and we
took notes and kept abreast of what was
happening at that time
we were debating a bill which is very
much almost very much in the news today
it was called the bracero bill it was a
bill allowing
immigrant workers from the south of our
borders to come into
california and arizona and new mexico to
work
the fields and harvest the fruit and
things like that and it was pretty
controversial even then
and i
turned around noticed some people came
in the door which was to my left
upstairs and then i turned around and
looked at them and
you know i figured they were just
tourists like so many people
and i paid no more attention to them
for some reason another i've never been
able to fathom this i decided i couldn't
hear very well
and i still have that problem today
and so i moved my seat
further down the aisle we had stools
there so i could be almost directly
above the speakers theirs
so i could hear better which was true
you could hear better
and it wasn't 10 seconds after i moved
that i heard this loud popping or pow
pow pow
and i turned around in my seat
to my left
and looked up and i see
these people are standing up with guns
in their hands and the woman was
standing with them and she had a big
flag
and she was unfurling the
waving the flag back and forth and i
ducked underneath the ledge we had a
ledger writing ledge and a phone right
there
and i subsequently found out i cut my
hand
and i got on the phone
and to enter intercom to the office and
i said there's a shooting going on out
here to my boss
and
everybody was scaring and running around
and i noticed
basically some people who were in the
gallery
visitors who were grappling with these
people and pushing them out the door
i was in the back benches in the corner
waiting to
be called to go to the various members
chairs to determine what they needed a
call came in i was in the first chair i
got up to go and i took about two or
three steps
and i
recall hearing what i thought at the
time sounded like firecrackers
a lot almost as if you lit a pack of
firecrackers through them fast rapid
reports
but in reality about after the third
step i got sprayed with what
made me feel was sand or ash or stone
and as a young man i had done a lot of
target
practice in quarries
so i was well aware of what a bullet
does when it hits and glances off a
stone it sets off a spray and it felt
like the same thing and immediately i
remember thinking by golly this these
are gunshots they're not
firecrackers so i hit the floor and
that's right behind the elevated floor
of the house
and then within a matter of a few
moments the the firing ceased and there
was a lot of
commotion on the floor or
disorganization
but because i had an early realization
of what was going on
my first instinct to see whether anyone
was hurt and my best friend as a matter
of fact
who was also a page bill emerson who i'd
met
that about just several well a year and
a half before that time but we were
roommates and best friends at school
he was also in the corner and when my
sign was made immediately i got up and i
got bill and we both went on the floor
and we determined that they needed
stretchers
and some people were wounded so we we
tried to organize the pages and other
people to help us out to get these
conveyances
and over the process of the next half
hour or so
we participated in carrying three of the
members out to the ambulances and the
last member that we took out we went to
the hospital with him
it's now a famous picture in several
respects it's the picture of the year
uh
1954 on in life magazine
and it was taken right outside the doors
of the house as we're starting on down
the steps of the capitol
the fellow was finger-pointing in front
is my best friend bill emerson he was a
member of congress from missouri in a
page with me
and then i'm immediately behind him on
the stretcher with the glasses on there
that's me when i was 15 years old then
another page is on the other side bill
goodwin from michigan and the three of
us were involved in carrying out about
three members of congress we did not
anticipate that it would ever happen it
was you know very calm place where
government activity was being carried on
it was open to the public we didn't ever
think that anyone would violate that
friendliness or that openliness but they
did
uh and i realized that
that would significantly change the
congress in the future and democracy in
a large way that people now were acting
in terrorist activity to accomplish
something
and so i'd have to say probably was one
of the early wasn't the earliest
terrorist activities in the united
states by a long shot but was the or
certainly the earliest in my lifetime